[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want we got hop back
hello you know what i think the last
time you were here you weren't engaged
yet
oh really yeah oh wow you got engaged
congratulations
congrats how'd you do it where'd you do
it
why did you do it yeah
it was back when we could still travel
freely
i went to greece in santorini
um how romantic is it as beautiful as it
is in the pictures
i it was amazing it was really amazing
but is it blue
it's really blue and it's really white
and the buildings are all white looking
all right and we were um out in the
ocean
a whole day so i think we got um was it
some poisoning
oh [ __ ] yeah i've never i've never heard
of it
when you get rashes all over no i didn't
get rashes but
it's basically i think it's like it's
basically your body overheating and your
your brain overheating
like a heat stroke heat stroke yeah but
really severe
to the point that i guess um there's a
state called confusion
where it's like your brain can't really
comprehend stuff and
i swear you know i would look at the
curtains and they would start moving
like an acid trip yeah well i've never
oh yeah
i wouldn't know but i'm assuming it
would be yeah you do you yeah
sucky hail mate no it's not that he was
just doing acid it wasn't even
that greek acid that um i proposed so we
were
both so while you guys were like oh [ __ ]
afterwards you like
so what was the proposal story like does
her yes even mean it yeah does she know
she said yeah
does she even remember she's like nah
did i engage
no it was on the ocean no it was um like
it
like on the deck of the hotel rooms nice
sunset
um moving curtains that came afterwards
but yeah i think it was you know it was
nice very personal you know
kind of played around with different
ideas what i wanted to do but i think at
the end of the day
it was you know just about us and how we
can remember it so
did she was she expecting or some one of
the like oh
i didn't know in my mind i was like okay
there's no way she's gonna know yeah you
know
she was already completely new
i mean i think it didn't help that i was
up until
4am for like two weeks straight trying
to look for the perfect
place to go and the fact that i asked
her hey do you want to go to south
africa for a day
uh because there was this one um this
place called giraffe manor
and it's like this hotel that's
surrounded by
giraffes it's really nice and i think
there was only like one day available
for that so i asked you oh let's just go
there for a day she's like okay
something like why would you go there
for a day you know
yeah away from why it's too special no
it was supposed to be spain
this is too big of an occasion
because it's too special we would do
random stuff like that
we usually go to monkey manor so this is
very unusual
because when we went to vietnam it was
literally like hey
let's go get vietnamese coffee in
vietnam because that would
just be fun yeah you know so i [ __ ] you
saying [ __ ] like that
let's go get pizza in naples because it
sounds delicious
but it's worth it though the coffee in
vietnam is out
i would go there just for the coffee all
the time the european version of it
let's get monsters in the u.s
i like that you did it just for you guys
personally though i think that's cool
because i think that there's this whole
wave now where everyone's trying to get
clicks
and like no one was there no one's not
oh
yeah and i think i don't know you could
have really grew your followers at that
moment
could have been i thought of you know
yeah
you know cargo from this whole thing or
making this but then at the end of the
day i just thought
i don't know if uh just a short-term
value is going to mean something when
i'm
you know eight years old or if i'm still
like there's some cats out there who are
basically
they make a video about that how dope
they are as a guy
to be doing all this [ __ ] and then like
at the end of it they don't want me and
you don't even know the chick's name
like it's all about the guy yeah the
[ __ ] dude's like
the [ __ ] dudes like you know whatever
whatever they're doing i've seen guys
like the most elaborate thing ever where
it's like they rent out a [ __ ] entire
um what is it flash mob or whatever yeah
flash mob yeah
and the chick gets out bounced around
what's going on the guy's like standing
on a podium like all the cameras are on
him and [ __ ] will you marry me
yeah yeah they basically do a talent
show and then at the end of it they get
down on one knee and go like will you
marry me and you don't even know the
chick's name like you i've watched these
videos i'm like who is this
chick you need to tell me one thing
about her other than you love her a lot
but it's all about them it's about the
guy like making himself look so sick
and then you know sitting there and
editing the video and she's like hey do
you want anything
like you want to go out and he's like
baby i'm editing i'm so busy right now
babe i can't
just see all of it i'm so excited
they're engaged now
i'm sure a lot of people like they fall
you know
into that i don't say trap but you know
that that quality and i'm sure there's
certain qualities to that too you know
but why you gotta be so nice what do you
mean
way to say nothing at all [ __ ]
political man here
running for california governor that's
not what i wanted you know yeah so
what did she want what if she wanted the
flashback what's her name really that's
not what she wants what's her name we
don't even know her name you've been
talking about her for
six minutes tina atkinson yes
that would be so sad if that is what she
wanted she's like no but i could
probably
i mean i hope i was able to tell that
that are you guys gonna get dual
citizenship i don't know
i don't know if i can i think well do
you have a british city no i just have a
japanese passport and then i i could
have got an english one but i don't
think our parents
uh applied for it when we were there so
it's just japanese and i forget how it
works
i think japanese passport you you gotta
denounce your japanese citizenship right
but then
yeah i don't know worth it for the
coffee
but
the japanese passport though is way
better than the american one because you
can [ __ ] go everywhere
you can even go to like north korea or
something really i don't know i made
that one now that's where you should
i want to see the giraffes in north
korea dude holy [ __ ]
they got them there there's marshall
i've heard kim jong-un has a zoo though
like in north korea there's a zoo yeah
he has a zoo
is it jesus or is it like for the public
it's just his
like michael jackson do you think the
veterinarians are like
these are the healthiest animals in the
world yeah they're really healthy
they're the so where's gina from uh
she's originally from missouri
yeah and then uh we met in vegas she
used to
be a hair stylist there and now she
moved out here it's been
i think like five six years now did you
meet in the club
was she like oh i like you have an
accent or something
what is that oh we're working
together um you sound different
you sound different what are you like
chinese or something
it doesn't sound chinese yeah no she she
hates clubs so
she's like i hate the chinese
i'm good i hate the chinese actually
when did you know
that she was the one that she said she
hated the training
he's like me too you started crying oh
my god
me too racist proposals
that's a good question though um you
guys have been together for a while
right
yeah yeah eight eight years now um
but still how do you know did you play
the blind your relationship is as old as
this channel
i i don't know i'm
just a feeling did you knew it did you
know it like from the beginning
or like kind of built into it like a
couple years in you're like oh man i
think she's the one or was it like from
the start you're like
i know um you got to think about this
for your wedding vows yeah oh yeah
that's not like i feel like as a as a
dancer you probably
sampled the world yeah
i feel like eyebrows so you know you
know
you sampled the world so i'm excited for
his non-answer for this
he's like i've never traveled anywhere
he's the definition of tread carefully
he's like why the [ __ ] did i come here
no i think it was really nice that um
she
she didn't know me at all you know
because i feel like when you meet
someone
that already knows or has an image of
you you know it's
it's nice and i think um for a
for a man for a male it's such a you
know
easy pickup game sort of thing you know
but i feel like
yeah yeah but then it's sort of like um
did you sell that to joe
oh sorry they just see your image you
know and it is slightly different so it
was really nice to get to know someone
completely from scratch both sides there
are both ways
i think that was really nice and at the
time when i met her
um sadly that was like a lot more rarer
you know to make people
like that because people are just trying
to use you for free dance lessons and
[ __ ]
they got it i get it you never know when
they're
there just for the free lessons today's
video is brought to you by
fields alright so you know our good
buddy david he is so
scared of heights yeah i took him hiking
i can't believe he accepted but you know
the type of hikes we do we climb we
don't really hike
and he hates heights yeah and what blew
my mind though
is that he was able to take this way
better than
you know before and he's like you know
what i think it is
i think it's the cbd oil and before we
went up you know
um i had some feels and then like we all
took some to kind of relax our nerves
and anxiety and obviously it's not a
cure
for phobias or you know it's not
something that's going to get you
over these things but what it does do at
least for me
and my friends is it helps calms us down
when we do feel anxious or whatever so
yeah
he was able to focus a lot more instead
of worrying about all of his like
fear of heights and anxiety and whatever
and then he was blowing his mind he was
like man i can't believe like
i'm just chilling out right now like
like this is
usually scaring the crap out of me and
then so
he pretty much you know attributes all
that to cbd oil
oh yeah so if you don't know what feels
is it's premium cbd that's delivered
right to your door and like josie just
put it right underneath your tongue and
it calms you down and it helps with a
bunch of
issues like sleeplessness anxiety and
like he said it's not
a cure but it does reduce some of those
angsty
feelings that you don't like so feliz
has us feeling our best every day and
right now if you go to feels.com
off the record you can get 50 off your
first shipment
plus free shipping that's feels.com f
e a l s dot com slash off director to
get 50
off your first shipment plus free
shipping
thank you feels but yeah i don't know i
feel like it's something that definitely
grew
you know um as we went and
we're still going together um
yeah just just a feeling i guess you
know are kids part of the equation i
would love to yeah but
like now we're dancing a few years she's
a dancer too right
no no no no yeah she's like a hairstyle
she's a hairstylist yeah
yeah no i mean um i'm ready whenever i
mean
it's just so even now like if it
happened now you're just like ah [ __ ] it
probably yeah
are you sure you're not a surfer you're
too chill bro
i think you should try surfing you'd be
pretty good i tried it once and i hated
it
i hated it you haven't you have a
[ __ ] vibe though man
dancers do though a lot of dancers well
not not all of them i know some dancers
too
this is this is different yeah wait what
about it just like
free-floating well no it's like you want
to have kids definitely yeah
like whatever absolutely yeah it's just
i don't know it's like cheery
just position because there's other
dancers you ask them and they're like oh
not now i still like gotta wait till
this part of my career
i still want to accomplish this we're
like do you want to have kids like nah i
don't think so dude
[Laughter]
no i mean i feel like if you you know
if he goes travel and see completely
different cultures
and like different like levels of life
whatever
it's like anything is possible you just
you know you kind of make it
work what's the shittiest thing about
greece
you want to hear some negativity out of
it let's see what you got grease
top three top i don't even know if
there's three bad things about it
um and you gotta complete the sentence
the shittiest thing about greece is
i don't think i know enough about it i
definitely only know the tourism side
the taxis you hated the taxis right no
no they're very nice
i mean you're talking to a guy that had
heat exhaustion and he still
executed a proposal and he remembers
nothing but a beautiful moment like he
had sun poisoning and he refused to
blame the sun
[Laughter]
i didn't even expect that because you
know i've
been in the sun my not my whole life but
i've never gotten that so i was so
surprised
wait why or what was it that you had to
do to
get better like see the moon
see the moon and just
wait sleep drink water yeah yeah yeah
but it was bad it was like really bad so
when did you start feeling the symptoms
throughout the day like
it wasn't until like
dinner-ish after the proposal but we've
never
either of us have gotten it so we were
like what's going on
but when you propose though you get an
adrenaline dump you feel like
afterwards you're just like yeah you're
so tired i feel like not me because i'm
not dude right here
i i did feel like hella tired afterwards
yeah i felt just because you're so pent
up the whole day yeah so we're gonna go
to
tai fung and then we get yo bro honestly
it was very nerve-wracking like
really i was freaking you already know
she's probably gonna say yes right i
don't know dude
[Laughter]
i don't know you guys are high school
sweethearts of course yeah but still a
lot can go wrong in that time
really yeah yeah of course i went to the
wedding too huh cause i was [ __ ]
nervous i was so nervous for the wedding
i don't know why
there was gonna be like three people
there well you thought casey was gonna
be like actually
i don't want to do it no i don't think
it was the fear of rejection it was just
like
fear of the moment yeah like the fear of
the moment is just such a big moment
so official huh well it's also such a
build up but you don't even want to
blink that day because you just don't
want to miss anything
you just want to see and experience
everything i was saying my vows
into a [ __ ] microphone which was also
weird i'm not used to that at all but
the whole i was like i was kind of
tearing up earlier
little [ __ ] yeah not a little [ __ ] and
the whole time bro i was like i would
say like a friend i'd be like
you are the love of
my life and i kept sniffling the whole
[ __ ] time
and i was sweating because i was like
this is awful this is a terrible vows
right
and then we got divorced the day after
that's tight isn't it weird you got to
say your vows like
openly yeah bro i was like what i got to
do this shouldn't that be private
yeah that's how i felt but i think
that's a guy's way of getting out there
there needs to be witnesses
for tradition man could be like i saw
those [ __ ] get married that's a greek
card marriage have i ever seen that's
why they have a witness right yeah
even like legally you need witness yeah
is that why they it's an old school
thing you know like you you know it's
like yeah they could [ __ ] because i
witnessed them getting married now you
know it's official now it's okay yeah
yeah and they're like yeah they really
do love each other because they [ __ ]
had their vows and all that stuff they
said it to all of us
that's how it goes they said it to all
of us you know what another weird like
thing is like you have to announce like
your businesses on newspapers back in
the day or you still have to now too or
like if you change your name
yeah that hasn't changed yeah last time
you guys looked at a newspaper
[ __ ] when was the last time i moved just
kidding
it's got to be at least a year like i
haven't even felt a newspaper in a long
time
i miss having like those black
fingertips
you know and like trying to make the
paper stand
yeah do you remember when you had to
look at movie show times at the in the
calendar section no i used to call
yeah yeah and then you have to wait
forever because they're saying all the
[ __ ] movie times and i'm like
or if a friend talked to you during the
movie you're listening to
you're like oh [ __ ] i listen to the
whole thing i like saving it and then
when i get a haircut
i put it on the table and then i cut my
hair like this
wait so right now yeah what are you guys
planning for your wedding then
when uh it was supposed to be uh this
september but
yeah i think we're going to move it to
next september because um
so another year yeah just because um
it's not that fun right now yeah well i
don't know i can't really dance
i didn't i didn't want to kind of um put
close people on the spot of like oh is
it rude if we say no
and this and that that feeling you know
that's when you find out who your real
friends are
and then you say all right that was a
fake invitation you're not gonna get it
to the next one that's
that's what you're telling are you going
to do a dance number at your wedding
better be the sickest one i don't know
i don't know honestly it's not will you
be spitting on your head
somewhere can you spin on your head no
why not dude you're some kind of dancer
right
it's like a specialty you're some kind
of dancer right
i'm not i'm not good enough if it does
like asking a heart surgeon like you do
brain surgery right
i mean you're a surgeon that's how it
works doesn't it i'm just let down
that's all
i don't know i mean we might might not
it's
sadly it's not that important of a
part i mean it will happen if it happens
if not
or some sort of artistic expression at
your wedding
probably yeah i think i just want um
ourselves and the people there to have a
great day
you know and if the dancing helps with
that great i think what makes the
wedding
now in this century is the bride and
groom surprise
wedding and when they do gangnam style
yeah
it's so old dude the best [ __ ] is when
they try to go viral in the beginning of
it
of the wedding like they do some kind of
coordination thing where you're just
like oh here we go
it's like oh no the swat team is here
and then oh no the swat team was here
how did they know about this and also
when props start coming out of nowhere
and it's like okay
it's like dude everyone's doing the same
[ __ ] your aunt and uncle come down the
aisle
the chris brown song
oh yeah and it was a lot of those yeah
from the office
yeah i love how cheesy it is because
every single one think they're like
so next level it's so good but they're
all the same so yeah
it's exactly the same they're like we're
gonna be the [ __ ] waiting of all
weddings it's like
uh it's a format that you guys follow
it's not that new
i was actually supposed to go to a
wedding this weekend a covered wedding
no no so they
we got invited like months ago well we
got to save the dates
and and then i saw it on my calendar for
for this saturday
and i was like oh [ __ ] so i hit up the
bride and i was like
hey are you still having your wedding i
never got an invite and it's still in my
calendar like what's happening like no
communication and she was like oh
actually we're moving into june
and i was like oh okay but i'm like it
could have been a weekend
wedding and then that would have been
weird i haven't been to a wedding during
these times like
i like how you are more responsible
about the wedding
no updates yeah no she actually told me
she's like i posted it on instagram and
facebook and i'm like
because she's like there was just too
many i don't follow you no i was like i
almost never opened instagram anymore i
literally never okay have you seen how
many followers i got
i got way too many damn people on my
feed too how am i supposed to see your
[ __ ]
no and then i went to her instagram and
she i didn't see anything so i was like
oh whatever no but i'm like all right
well i changed it to my calendar
but i was actually really curious though
to see like what would have happened
because it's
mexican weddings are not small so it's
like a big family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you